[Music]
I've been thinking about this movie for
like 10 years
there's a part of me that can't believe
we're making this film it's epic jumbo
every detail has a detail inside of it
if you pumped a 10 year old full of
Zoloft and had him get your groceries
that's like this movie I wanted to make
a film where it feels like you've been
through a life or even through a person
I feel a great responsibility
to deliver something amazing
I'm visiting my mother tomorrow are you
expecting it to be safe
it's like a Jewish Lord of the Rings but
he's just going to his mom's house
I want to put you in the experience of
being a loser
are you on your way